okay so I do want to start today with
this story of Donald Trump telling this
group of progressive first-year members
of Congress to go back to their original
countries this is something he tweeted
over the weekend it's been getting a ton
of attention but I want to do it right
and I don't want to do just the haha
stupid Trump he doesn't realize that
Puerto Rico is part of the United States
thing because there's actually a lot to
say here and a lot of it is is not
actually being said and I think that
some important points are being missed
so first of all the facts Donald Trump
lost it on Twitter yesterday he sent out
this series of tweets directed at this
group of first term of female Democratic
members of the House this includes
presumably Alexandria Castillo Cortes
Ilhan Omar Rasheeda Talib Ayana Presley
here from Boston is sort of presumed or
believed to be part of this group and of
course AOC is American Ilan Omar was
born in Somalia came to the United
States is an American citizen Ayana
Presley's from the US Rasheeda Talib is
from the United States and we will look
immediately at the tweets that Donald
Trump sent out quote so interesting to
see quote progressive Democrat Congress
women who originally came from countries
whose governments are a complete and
total catastrophe the worst most corrupt
and inept anywhere in the world if they
even have a functioning government at
all now loudly and viciously telling the
people of the United States the greatest
and most powerful nation on earth how
our government is to be run why don't
they go back and help fix the totally
broken in crime-infested places from
which they came then come back and show
us how it's done these places need your
help badly
you can't leave fast enough I'm sure
that Nancy Pelosi would be very happy to
quickly work out free travel
arrangements so the obvious immediate
reflexive response is hold on a second
they're mostly Americans what's Trump
talking about their original countries
Ilan Omar immigrated to the US from
Somalia but as an American citizen
otherwise if we're talking about
Americans here now if you mean the
countries that their ancestors came from
then it actually gets even stupider
because everyone came from somewhere
else in the US other than Native
Americans and even they you go back far
enough came from Africa depending on how
far back you go alexandria Ocasio cortez
is Puerto Rican by origin which is part
of the United States another point of
confusion that Donald Trump can't seem
to understand so this is dripping with
xenophobia some are calling it racism
immediately semantics games start about
what is racism what does that really
mean your mind reading what Donald
what's in Donald Trump's head I don't
want to get into that we're actually
gonna deal with that separately maybe
tomorrow or Wednesday
AOC is more American than Trump or at
least as American in that trumps
grandfather came from Germany Germany
Germany is definitely not the United
States
ayoh sees grandparents I believe came to
New York from Puerto Rico which is part
of the United States but I actually
don't think this is the right focus I
believe that the correct focus here has
to be to call out and not fall for
Donald Trump's ploy to foment division
on the left and to distract from all of
the crises and failures in which he's
involved some of which I'm going to tell
you about a little bit later yeah there
are serious things to figure out about
the direction of the Democratic Party
Nancy Pelosi is to the right of the
party some of these new members want to
pull the party to the left you don't
have to agree with everything that these
new members represent it's fine and
healthy to disagree on issues but this
is Donald Trump trying to rile people up
on the left
Trump has chosen to pick the Pelosi side
in the Pelosi versus new progressive
Dems quote fight which is a fight mostly
being fomented by people who would
benefit from the Democratic Party being
divided this isn't surprising but we
really shouldn't fall for this stuff so
number one recognized the pattern Donald
Trump creates a controversy then backs
off of it and moves on after
successfully distracting from things he
doesn't want the news cycle focusing on
or version 2 of this is Donald Trump
creates a problem and then claims to
have solved the problem oK we've seen
this a bunch of times
Trump called off an attack on Iran well
yeah but he called for the attack attack
first and authorized it and then he
called it off when he supposedly got
more information about the number of
civilians that were going to be killed
Trump you know created a problem with
Iran by bailing on the Iran nuclear deal
and now he says he's going to fix it and
he's open to a new deal well we wouldn't
be in this situation if he didn't cause
the problem in the first place so this
is Trump's a sort of pattern his MO and
in this case mere participation in the
dumb pissing matches that Trump
generates means that we lose so that's
that's really important to understand
now more importantly there's another
theme Trump is playing the role of
Russia with the Democratic Party by
picking a side in order to divide us
okay so understand this the Trump tweets
are crazy but Trump is trying to divide
the left for his benefit by taking aside
in Pelosi versus new progressives aoc is
American telling her to go back to her
country as ignorant xenophobia but don't
fall for it because in the same way that
Russia's goal in meddling with foreign
countries internal politics it goes
beyond the United States of course but
just using the u.s. an example it's not
that Trump is beloved by Russia or
whatever Russia figured out that Trump
would be extremely divisive for the
country and that's why they wanted to
help him in the same way Donald Trump
knows that taking aside in Pelosi versus
new progressive Democrats is potentially
going to divide the Democratic Party
arguably to his advantage
so the takeaway has to be we have 16
months left until the election we have
the numbers most Americans are disgusted
by this type of crap so let's not allow
Donald Trump to play these games and
further divide us and let's not let
stupidity distract us from the actual
and real scandals that are going on
for example the connection between
Donald Trump and rapists Jeffrey Epstein
every day that the headlines are Trump
tweets about go back to your countries
instead of the headlines being Trump is
accused of rape by one of the same
people that accused Jeffrey Epstein of
rape that is a win for Donald Trump and
you can't ever forget about the fact
that there is a constant distract
Thun going on either consciously or
unconsciously just don't take the bait
don't fall for it okay really important
that we not fall into the same circles
that have succeeded in helping Donald
Trump distract from really serious
problems that are going on many many
times over the last two and a half years
one of today's sponsors is impeach the
card slap game you can't slap Donald
Trump in real life but you can slap them
in this hilarious fast-paced two-player
card game and you can get it for ten
percent off when you go to david
pakman.com slash impeach impeach the
card game is awesome for parties or when
you're having a few drinks I've been
playing it with some friends of mine it
combines clever satire about the Trump
administration with really funny
high-quality cartoon artwork all in a
very lively card game that's easy to
learn but it stays interesting every
time you play it because of how well
designed it is and how much thought went
into the humor and the political
commentary impeach the cards slap game
is perfect if you're looking for
something fun and casual to do with your
politically minded friends or family
members it'll make a perfect gift for
anyone you know who has a sense of humor
about Donald Trump and when you go to
david pakman.com slash impeach not only
will you get 10% off the game you can
also get 10% off all of the other
hilarious clothing and accessories in
their online store t-shirts coffee mugs
tote bags featuring funny political
cartoons about trump that you can't find
anywhere else get a super fun witty gift
for yourself or someone you know whether
it's impeach the card slap game or
anything else in the gift shop and get
10% off all of it when you go to david
pakman.com slash impeach